[Music]
curry on the drive the floater in the
paint short
wiggins tips it but right to davis
james running the floor pass to caruso
back to james and he's fouled
draymond greed would not let him get a
layup
and james goes down holding his head
the officials discussing
[Applause]
i think they're going to take a look at
it to see if it's a flagrant
[Applause]
possible flavor and there's contact to
the head of
lebron james would be interesting to see
the conclusion that they come up with
here but this clearly with the right
hand
of draymond green to the head
goes up the block this is a huge call
again because it will be free throws and
possession
as green picks up his fourth personal
that's going to be a flagrant it's going
to be a flagrant and it shouldn't be
but it it will be well let's bring in
steve jaby get his thoughts all right
steve
your thoughts on draymond green and that
foul is that a flagrant
[Applause]
all right steve thank you i'm just
heartened that steve agrees with both of
you
no he didn't agree with us he we said
it's going to be called he says it's not
oh but he'd know he agrees with you and
that you don't think it should be right
it's going to be called right
but clearly to me there was contact on
the head according to the rules but not
everything to the head
is a flagrant foul you need to make up
your mind sir
no i i don't think it is one i think it
will be
called one and i hate when games